welcome back so we're talking about
machine learning and the different types
of machine learning what is a machine
learning model and in this video I'm
going to introduce you to neural
networks which is one of the most
powerful architectures in machine
learning
so we're going to talk about neural
networks which interestingly just about
10 years ago these were barely talked
about just over you know in 15 years ago
these were barely talked about as a type
of machine learning most industrial
machine learning was based on support
Vector machines or decision trees or
some kind of other basic regression and
in the last 10 years neural networks
have come to absolutely dominate most
types of machine learning most machine
learning tasks from image classification
to large language models to many physics
and Engineering applications neural
networks are a standard
now neural networks are not the only
type of machine learning they are a very
important type of machine learning one
of the reasons that they're so useful is
because they have this arbitrary
function approximation property which
means with a sufficiently deep neural
network you can essentially approximate
any function if you have enough training
data and a large enough Network that's
really useful so they're very very
expressive they can capture multi-scale
features like for facial recognition or
image recognition they can play on large
and small features and they're very very
expressive
they've been around for a long time
since the perceptron in 1958 by
rosenblatt but they really really took
off recently in the last 10 years or so
with the imagenet in 2012. okay again
this 2012 powerful demonstration that
kind of revived neural networks was
based on a massive trained labeled sorry
labeled data set that allowed this to be
trained okay so the data is equally
important but again with enough data
these are very very expressive and
Powerful
function approximators so good
candidates for machine learning
so what is a neural network essentially
a neural network is designed to be
biologically inspired at least
originally it was inspired by trying to
learn how animal learning occurs through
a literal network of coupled neurons in
a brain or in a nervous system
and so the idea
you have inputs and outputs each of
these circles is what's called a node or
a neural unit and essentially each of
those nodes does some basic mathematical
computation on its inputs and it gives
an output so a single neural unit will
take data in the sum of its inputs and
it will give an output that is a
function of those inputs
like a sigmoidal function or a
hyperbolic tangent function because
again that's biologically motivated our
neurons you know if they get little
enough signal they don't Spike at all if
they have enough signal it's not like
they can Spike infinitely fast so
there's some saturation and there's some
region of kind of linear response in the
middle but again that's just
biologically inspired and that's not
your only type of neural unit there are
other types of neural units modern
neural networks often use this thing
called a rail a relu a rectified linear
unit that essentially looks like this
it's zero up to some
minimum input and then it's linear
afterwards
and so each of these kind of neurons or
nodes is stacked together into a neural
network into a sequence of computations
that builds an output from the inputs
so you'll see that this data on the
input whatever this input signal is it
goes into these two neurons which do a
computation the output of those two
neurons go into two other neurons and
the sum of these inputs is weighted and
then goes through this non-linear
function and that gives me the output
here similarly with this neuron and then
those two are the input to this final
neuron which again does some weighted
computation and that gives the output
so at its heart this is really just a
kind of nested composition of functions
with some some weighting that tells me
how how strongly these should be
connected
and usually these weights are the free
parameters that you actually learn when
you train a neural network model you
start maybe initialize these with random
values or something like that and you
use
um
the learning process to update these
weights to update how this neural
network is connected together
and you know this one is a pretty simple
one you can have very very tall layers
you can have many many many layers and
the idea is that each of these layers
kind of does an abstraction of a
computation it kind of abstracts a very
very big computation into smaller pieces
again motivated kind of by how the
visual system in animals is known to
work
so the perceptron which is the one layer
neural network
proposed decades ago essentially takes a
an input Vector so you take your input
data whatever it is maybe it's an image
or a Time series
it takes a weighted sum of that inputs
it runs it through this non-linear
function and it gives an output so the
output is literally that sigmoidal
function Sigma times a weighted sum of
the inputs that's just a weight Vector
times x so mathematically this is very
simple to write down
um it's kind of this cool quote that I
learned from Bing Brunton rosenblatt New
York Times 1950s says perceptrons in the
future will be able to recognize people
and call out their names hear speech in
one language and instantly translate it
to speech a writing of another language
it took a long time for that Vision to
come to fruition but this is very much
like the technology that we're seeing
today with modern deep neural network
architectures so they're not these
shallow kind of one layer perceptrons
now we have many many layers doing this
kind of hierarchical set of abstract
computations but we are actually
starting to achieve these types of goals
which is really cool and so the
revolution between then and now is
really the Deep neural network or deep
learning as we call it today and again
deep means different things to different
people but generally speaking having
multiple layers of abstraction of the
computation
allows you to have much more expression
expressive architectures and much higher
performance
the caveat is now all of these free
parameters that you have to learn
require a lot of training data and
really big really fast computers to
train and to learn all of these free
parameters all of these connection
weights to train this model to fit that
data so you need much larger data sets
and much faster computers but we live in
a wonderful time and we do have that
data and we do have those computers and
so we can train very deep very large
neural networks usually you're only
limited by you know how much memory you
have on your graphics processor unit to
fit all of these free parameters and
modern architectures we're learning how
to train in a distributed way across
many Computing platforms so you can have
even larger models like these large
language models like chat GPT that we're
seeing today
so much more expressive because of this
depth and complexity of the computation
and again we know from how animals
process information for example in their
visual system there are layers literal
actual layers you can see when you
dissect of abstraction that maybe will
identify you know translations or
corners or features or edges and then
they might abstract into bigger and
bigger features that's kind of what the
layers of this neural network do so one
layer might find you know small features
and then another layer might say okay
well I have these eyes and they're this
distance apart and then the next layer
might do another computation and you can
imagine this thing getting
hierarchically more complex with depth
so deep neural networks are currently
the strategy we use to solve really hard
at machine learning modeling problems in
a lot of cases
and so there are many many many
architectures out there many different
types of neural networks this is
actually an outdated figure this is um a
figure from uh our book data-driven
science and engineering by myself and
Nathan Kutz this is inspired by
um the the neural network Zoo from the
Asimov Institute and you can see this is
just a small selection from the large
menagerie of possible neural network
tools to solve different problems so
different architectures are suited for
different problems and depending on your
system you might choose one of these
and so one of the big issues today and
this is an open outstanding problem even
though neural networks are super
powerful one of the big open challenges
today is currently picking and choosing
and designing a neural network and
tailoring it to a particular problem is
very much like Alchemy we're kind of in
the Alchemy stages of neural networks
and machine learning what we would like
to do is learn the chemistry kind of the
we'd like to go from the Alchemy of
neural networks to the chemistry of
neural networks and understand what are
the physical principles that mean that
an auto encoder is better for one type
of task than another or that I should
use a recurrent neural network but not
this kind of recurrent neural network
this kind and so we are trying very hard
in the physical sciences and in
engineering to learn principles of how
to pair machine learning models neural
network models with different types of
modeling tasks especially in science and
engineering where we we don't just want
to try all of the algorithms and see
which one works and kind of cherry pick
the best one okay that's fine if you're
trying to increase ad revenue and you
know click through but we really want
better principles than that in the
future
and
actually a really interesting motivation
so we feel like there is an opportunity
to apply machine learning to physical
systems we can maybe build better fluid
simulators or design better super
materials with machine learning
but there is also a dual benefit that
when we apply machine learning to
systems that have physics in some cases
where we kind of know the answer that
can give us a real ground truth that we
don't have in other machine learning
applications to really start to in a
principled way understand and dissect
what that machine learning model is
doing and why one algorithm or
architecture might be better than
another so this is an ongoing process
trying to go from the Alchemy stages to
the chemistry stages in neural networks
now it's not like we don't know anything
we definitely are learning Lots about
what neural networks are good for what
types of data and in what circumstances
and so General kind of best practices
convolutional neural networks are great
for images if your data looks like an
image and there's kind of spatial
correlated structures you probably want
some kind of a convolutional
architecture in your neural network this
is really good when you have any kind of
of
multi-scale hierarchical organization in
your image and also if you have things
like translation translational
invariance so if I have a classifier and
I'm trying to classify if an image has a
dog in the image it shouldn't matter if
the dog is in one corner or the other
corner or the middle and convolutional
neural networks have this kind of
built-in translational invariant because
you're taking these little filters and
you're sliding them across your image
looking for features anywhere in the
image really good for images
convolutional neural networks so that's
a pairing
um
and you know there have been a lot of
really interesting studies that have
shown that these cnns kind of again just
like what we vaguely understand about
animal visual systems they
hierarchically pull out different kinds
of features in different layers so they
might pull out you know corners and
edges and you know things like that in
one layer they might pull out shapes and
abstractions in another layer and these
representations might get more
complicated as you have additional
layers of these cnns so kind of neat
um deeper understanding of what these
are doing
if you have audio data or data that
evolves in Time Time series data
typically we want recurrent neural
networks so most of the neural networks
we think about most of the ones I've
shown you are what are called feed
forward networks so the information
starts out on one side and just trickles
down or flows from left to right in a
feed forward fashion recurrent neural
networks what they do is they take
information from future from from
Downstream nodes and they feed those
back so that you get this feedback loop
and feedback loops allow you to do
things like have memory and model and
learn and memorize time series trends
that you would see in audio and general
temporal data so modeling differential
equations and systems that evolve in
time you're going to want to use
recurrent neural network architectures
very useful
my favorites favorites is an auto
encoder Network so if you have really
high dimensional data like you know big
images or flow fields or you know
scanning
electron microscope images or acoustic
data whatever large large data acoustic
images you might believe that there is
low dimensional structure in that data
in which case if you would have normally
done something like principal components
analysis or singular value decomposition
to find those patterns
you can also use an auto encoder Network
to learn those types of patterns
I would not recommend training a neural
network to do the principal components
analysis it's a very inefficient way of
doing something that you can do more
efficiently with linear algebra
this is because the classic principal
components analysis that we've been
doing for over 100 years
can be visualized as a very simple
neural network
that has essentially one middle layer
where you take your high dimensional
data you can press it down through this
information bottleneck to a low
dimensional state that is as small as
possible so that you can reconstruct an
estimate of the state from these very
few variables in Z this gives you a lot
of interpretability because these few
numbers are possibly understandable by a
human and you can visualize these
encoding and decoding matrices V with
with pictures
now the reason I'm showing you this is
because if you relax these assumptions
of a shallow and linear autoencoder
Network which would give you PCA if you
allow yourself to have a deep non-linear
autoencoder you can generalize principal
components and instead of learning a low
dimensional Subspace Z you can learn a
low dimensional sub manifold where your
Dynamics live or where your system lives
on Z and often you can get much better
compression and you still have highly
interpretable models so so autoencoders
essentially are the generalization a
non-linear generalization of principal
components analysis that allows you to
find really useful interpretable low
dimensional correlated structures in
your high dimensional data so I use this
all the time for physical systems one of
my favorite architectures
of neural networks how what they are how
they're built what are neurons what are
these computations
you know we do understand broad
categories like cnns and autoencoders
and you know recurrent neural networks
but there's still this very much an
Alchemy flavor to neural networks and so
we need more principles to understand
how to pair specific architectures with
specific problems systems with physics
Engineering Systems might help us
actually develop kind of those
principles of how to apply them
and I think I'll just end with some
cautions because everyone gets so
excited about neural networks myself
included we should remember that they're
not built for everything and they're not
perfect neural networks are notoriously
prone to overfitting which again if I
have a big enough Network and enough
training data not that big of a problem
um they are often struggle with
generalizability so if I um train a
neural network on images of a pendulum
oscillating it will learn to generate
new images of pendula oscillating or if
I generate you know if I train it on
images of apples falling it'll learn to
generate new movies of apples falling
it's not going to learn f equals ma it's
not going to be useful when we land you
know designed Rockets to land humans on
the moon you need to go beyond a simple
neural network to get this
generalizability that is a Hallmark of
physics okay
interpretability and explainability
these are very very complicated they
often have millions or billions of free
parameters so it's very hard to
understand how they work and how they
come to their conclusions that can be a
really big challenge when we're talking
about safety critical systems like you
know designing an aircraft or an
autopilot or a self-driving car I really
need interpretable explainable models
and even more than that sometimes I need
certifiable models
I need to bound the possibility of what
these models are actually going to do so
that I can design safety certifiable
controllers and things like that
uh and a lot of these issues of
overfitting generalizability
interpretability can be partially solved
by trying to incorporate physics into
the learning process into the
architecture into the training into the
loss functions and optimization
algorithms you use to train these and so
that's a big area of research we're
actively involved in it I'll definitely
talk about it a bit more in this series
but you know if you want more
interpretable explainable generalizable
neural networks generally speaking we
should take a cue from physics because
when I say interpretable and
generalizable you know you should be
thinking hey f equals m a is a pretty
good example of that how do we bake that
kind of model into a neural network
okay uh more to come thank you